[inaudible].
All right, well we could probably do
a show just on Facebook, but let's,
let's move to the others
because in a certain way,
I think Facebook is becoming
increasingly irrelevant,
at least in the political space that my
judgment of that may be slightly off,
but I just don't see that much
traction any more with young people.
Do you think that's basically fair?
I disagree. I think that Facebook,
I think that the majority of
these companies disseminate
their content through
the social media platform.
So I think that there are always
going to be relevant and there is,
they dominate the market in
terms of advertising revenue. Um,
even even the big news organizations,
uh,
disseminate their content through
Facebook. So I think it's,
I think they are relevant.
I don't know.
I don't know what the
trajectory of that is. Yeah.
I don't mean that they're irrelevant,
but it seems to me that the,
the conversation that I really think is
important about all of this seems to be
happening much more on Twitter.
I assume.
Not necessarily that the money in the
advertising and the mainstream media reach
and all of those things aren't relevant
on Facebook, but that the real sort of,
I don't know, the gestalt of this or
something is on Twitter and Youtube.
So that's the, let's ship
there for a second. So, uh,
Twitter, I'm sure you see me,
uh, tweeting all the time about the
shadow bands and the rest of it.
So what the hell is going on
with Twitter? Well, we went,
we went undercover into Twitter and
last year and early 2018 and we caught a
number of engineers describing
a shadow banning, uh,
removing posts. When people don't know
that they're sharing their content,
they don't know that they're being banned,
that we actually have quotes from the
engineers talking about what they have
done. I mentioned earlier with
this, a direct messaging expert,
a guy named [inaudible] Singh
who works on the Twitter DM team,
says that he can peruse all of
your messages, your private dms.
Uh, he says that there are key words
that Twitter uses to filter tweets,
uh, the American flag,
God guns. Uh, and then,
then we talked to another engineer,
not jump over the first one there.
So they can literally look at your direct
messaging. That's what they told us.
Private direct messages. They said they
have teams. This is a guy named Clay Hain.
So they have hundred hundreds plus
of people that, and he says, quote,
I've seen a lot of Dick pics on quote.
So I understand they have
to do some of this to, to,
to ban pornography and you know,
Gore and content.
But apparently this is what they told
us that I don't know why they'd have to
look at your private messages, but, and
they've also said that they don't do that.
So that's the thing.
Why do they say one thing in public?
Another thing in private is what
we've found. But, but again,
I try to only speak to what I can
actually a videotape of what the engineers
said.
And this Abenov for Draven guy was,
there was a congressional hearing with
a lobbyist. Ted Cruz did ask him, uh,
do you do this? And he
says, we do not do that.
Well then why did your engineer
say they were doing it?
So I just think they're being dishonest.
So that's the type of sort of underhanded
tactic they're using the shadow
banning cause you have no idea.
Again,
you just don't know when
you put something out.
Is this getting to all of
my people or is it not?
Or can some people not retweet it or the
rest of it? I mean it's a pretty clever,
if they were trying to silence people,
it's pretty clever way of doing it. Right.
I think that's the unethical part.
They don't tell people that they are
doing and they don't tell people their
political positions.
I just want them to be transparent.
I think Facebook kind of thing.
Not to go back to Facebook,
but they put out a thing. We are,
we are banning white nationalists.
Well at least they're telling us
where they stand. I'm not the,
not that that is a good thing,
white nationalism.
But if they were to do more of
that sort of thing and say we are,
we are taking an editorial
perspective in the New York Times,
The Washington Post. You can see on
the op Ed pages what they believe in.
They're there. They're rather transparent
about it. I would say more so.
So I think that these companies should
take an editorial position, but when,
when we hear,
um,
print icing at Twitter on the hidden
camera, say who talks like that,
who talks about God and the American
flag and guns must be a Russian Bot says
print icing at Twitter.
Well,
I'm fine with that as long
as you say it publicly,
as long as you make it part of your
editorial positions so that people know,
okay, this company is a,
is extremely left wing.
Any of the Banning's or any of this
ever happened to people on the left?
I know there were some instances maybe
with Auntie Phi accounts are a couple of
things like that,
but it always seems like
you have conservatives and
people on the right talking
about it. Yeah, I don't,
I'm not, to my knowledge,
and I think our reporting
overwhelmingly focused on,
on why he even mentioned Donald Trump's
account and insinuated that they were,
that they were working with the government
to give information to, I dunno,
deep state individuals.
This is Clay Haynes,
a network security engineer at Twitter
told us about Donald Trump's accounts.
I've never seen anything on the
other end of the spectrum from,
from my vantage point when Trump's
account got taken down for those couple of
hours. And then it turned
out to be just, what was it?
They said it was some accident or some
young, some low level guy did it for you.
That must've been like a Whoa,
that just shows you the power that any,
any individual here would have access
to be able to shut down. Even for our,
for our purposes, we're always,
I'm always trying to prove it.
Like I want to get them on tape admitting
why they did it. But there are the,
there are these,
you know,
I guess you could call them low level
people that do things that are not
acceptable. Um, and it's policed
more. So at Facebook I would say.
Yeah. Anything else going on with Twitter
and that's all that we reported on the
shadow banning the, the, the,
the, the private DM messages. Uh,
and the shadow banning were the big ones.
What do you make generally of the
political politization of Twitter
specifically? So, you know,
if you were to click on the search bar
on Twitter on any given day and you see
the Twitter moments, it's all, you know,
they're always showing you
the Trans Story of the day or,
or whatever the left is
leading with that day. They're
always sort of pushing
that down your throat. Um,
is that just consistent with everything
else you view these companies?
What I will say is that we have more
stories coming on, that sort of thing.
So I would, I would hold my tongue
because I don't want to scoop myself.
We've got a number of people
on the inside that are,
that are maybe focusing on the search
functions at these organizations.
So we'll, we'll, you'll
be, you have to stay tuned
to see what we young, yeah,
that wouldn't surprise me.
I mean when I searched certain people,
even if they're verified,
if they happen to be on the right,
sometimes they don't pop up.
But I get a zillion random accounts
before that. Or I often think that the,
um, the trending tab right. Seems like
it's completely manipulated. You know,
what they are commenting on
and what they're, you know,
cause sometimes there's a comment
beneath the trend or whatever.
It all just seems made up.
And,
and, and, and for project Veritas, the,
the priority is to prove it, is to,
is to catch them on tape admitting it.
And that is what we will do.
And we will have more stories soon.
Huh.
And all of this, all those
friends. So let's move to youtube.
We're on youtube right now. I've had
people in the past, years ago when I did,
at one time I did have an email address
from somebody of youtube and they told
me,
cause I kept saying,
people keep complaining that they
are unsubscribed from my channel.
I kept getting emails every day.
And one time someone from Youtube
admitted to me, they said,
there's a bug on your channel.
And we're trying to work it out
with a couple of weeks after that.
After I followed up a few times and then
I couldn't get any more information,
I got an email from the guy saying
I'm no longer handling this case.
And now you have to go to the,
you don't have an email
address to respond to any more,
go to the general tab and
complaining or whatever. Uh,
so I have to publicly
shame them all the time.
You probably see me doing this
with teams and youtube and Twitter.
Every time I get demonetized I fight them.
And then they usually not always lie.
Rose, for example, they did not re
monetize. Um, they didn't really,
they did not rule you monetize that one.
It was d monetized by the algorithm
and then confirmed by manual review.
Now that's their right to do that. Again,
you want some transparency with it.
Um,
but unsubscribes video's not going
out to feeds all of these things.
What evidence do we actually
have that these things are here?
Well,
we did a story in 2017 between the New
York Times reporter named Nick Dudek and
Youtube. And again, I can only talk
about what I report that that's my rule.
So I don't, I don't like to, to
comment on things that I don't,
I haven't had personal experience with,
but there was a relationship between
these networks like the New York Times and
hopping to post and, and Youtube.
And there, there are favors given to,
to these, uh, organizations
over say your show.
Um, and, and that's something that
we've, we've, we reported on an exposed,
so what would a favor look like?
Well,
preferential treatment and the end to
getting into the, the scientifics of it,
I'm not sure, but preferential
treatment where the video would, would,
would show up more frequently at
the top of the, of search query.
Um,
it's this Guy Nick Dudek who was a social
accounts video editor for The New York
Times, talked about his relationship
with this guy inside youtube.
So there's a sort of,
you know,
two way street there between the
two companies where favors are done.
But with the New York Times now,
why are they doing them favors? I,
that's what I was talking about earlier,
where these companies have enormous
power because even the likes of the old
media transmit their messages
through the new media.
That's where the majority of people get
their information from. So, um, but that,
that was that guy nick duty, actually the
executive editor of the New York Times.
Dean Baquet is his name. Actually
we believe, let that guy go.
He actually, uh, uh,
terminated Nick Dudek for
telling us this stuff.
No one reported on that. But, uh,
I don't know whether they terminated
him for telling the truth or for or for
lying about what he had said.
So how do you combat that?
The part where every time you guys
released something that I look at it,
I'm always hesitant to retweet it.
I've shared some of your videos sometimes,
but I'm always like, ah, if,
if this is the one where you
know he got duped or you know,
it's only being shared
by Breitbart or whatever,
then it's like you like basically that
you have some sort of secondary layer of
censorship to get through. Well, I'll
tell you what, we've done 200 acres,
Huffington post and buzzfeed and CNN.
They in touch in any of this. Well,
they have touched it.
I mean,
Anderson Cooper reported on this stuff
we did during the 2016 election on
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
are stories in the 2018 election,
made the New York Times. Um, we've
gotten a lot of local media coverage.
We've been in terms of being duped,
weave,
weave in and out of 200 undercover
investigators. They say things are edited,
they're edited out of context.
They're, they're not real. I mean,
and you actually ask them what
specific edits are you talking about?
Because to say that video is edited and
it's like saying words are arranged,
all journalism is edited and to
tell a story and they said, well,
you didn't wear the pimp costume and
the acorn office. Well you know, okay.
But I presented myself
as as a, as a pimp. Um,
and even the New York Times said that
and pimp protocol doesn't require wearing
of Pinot fought for to be a pimp who were
a big pink jacket and drive a Cadillac
vehicles. Um, and I said, well, there was
a scene change in the NPR investigation.
Okay. Is that the best you got? I mean, I,
there was a cutaway shot or the guy was
laughing and I was narrating over it in
200 investigations.
I mean,
they've printed 300 corrections
and attractions about me.
I have a wall in my office called
the wall of shame and it's all these
corrections and attractions about me.
The Washington Post that I went after
acorn due to an animus about African
Americans voting. They made it up.
Pulitzer prize winning reporter Carol,
letting just made something up
out of whole whole cloth. So,
I don't know. I think there is a,
I think it's not about the, um,
the, the, what we do is
real. The tapes, you see,
there's never been a case
where you saw wasn't real.
There was one thing with the
Washington Post that blew up.
They turn their cameras back around
on us and everyone, you know, said,
well that's unethical.
What exactly?
It was unethical about it because
we went undercover into CNN.
We infiltrated something called
a rain bros at which was a,
a gay group where this producer was in.
Nobody questioned the ethics of it.
Nobody questioned the ethics
because the end was so obvious.
And whether or not you think
that the means are justified,
depends upon whether you think there's a
compelling public interest and what you
are exposing.
So when these things get interrupted,
then people say it's unethical. But we
think that undercover work is justified,
particularly into the big 10 companies
and the big media due to the urgency of
the circumstances. But in
all of our work, no one's,
no one's ever able to actually say
what exactly has been fake about it.
And that's from my perspective or are
you shocked at actually how the collapse
of mainstream media has precipitated
so quickly at this point?
Like it seems to me that it's
just, it's over. I mean now,
just in the last couple of weeks now with,
with Trump and Russia and just the amount
that these people have just lied over
and over. And finally, thanks to
Twitter and Youtube and the rest of it,
if we're not being shadow and everything,
there's enough of us that can get
a counter narrative out there,
but they just keep doing it. Well, I think
it's the death of, I think it's, it's uh,
uh, you've covered,
cause I watch your show,
a lot of the political
reasons why media is dying,
but I actually think it's goes back to
Jefferey's Zucker said in the last two
weeks about, I don't know if you saw
that tweet where Brian Stelter said,
we're not investigators.
Well,
that was an unbelievable moment
because that's really, they're not,
they're not investigative reporters.
And people have to remember a thing about
CNN talking about CNN, CNN, we don't,
we're not investigators where journalists,
so here's the thing.
This is very important. People talk about
politics. People talk about, you know,
the media is algorithms,
but it's also economics.
Investigative reporting is very,
very expensive and it's a
naturally philanthropic activity.
Investigative reporting,
going back 40 50 years,
it was always a loss leader on
the company's balance sheets.
People have to remember these are,
these are businesses.
They're not interested in the public
interest. They're interested in,
in generating a profit,
and that's fine, but,
but don't pretend that you
serve the public interest.
We had a CNN insider on tape. John
Barfield said, this is a business,
the CEO of CNN,
Jeff Zucker told us a stop
talking about the climate accords.
Let's get back to Russia.
It's about ratings. It's not
about ethics and it's been,
you know, spending. It's
important to illustrate though.
You're not saying there's anything
inherently wrong with that.
He's allowed to make money. He's
allowed to do business. But,
but don't pretend you're operating in
the public interest because investigative
reporting, and let, let, let me, let me,
you had mentioned, you know, people don't,
if people are wary of what we do,
it's naturally the tip, the spear.
You have to use deception to a degree.
Either you deceive your source
or you deceive your audience.
The problem with journalism and the reason
why it's in decline is because these
leakers,
these sources and government and elsewhere
intentionally transmit stuff to the
media and they paired it to the
masses. A. I. E. Jeff Zucker saying,
we don't investigate what we're told.
And that's what, you know, what,
what has been referred
to as a pseudo event.
They create something they
transmitted unquestionably.
And there's the economic factor.
There's a symbiotic relationship
between people and power.
What we do at Veritas is we,
we go undercover and we,
we completely defy the narrative.
And that's,
and most networks don't
want to air it because?
Because it's risky because
it's questioning that the
normative order of things,
it's easier to do little videos
about squirrels on skateboards. Now,
I did this big story during the election,
you know,
for Bob Creamer resigned from
the Hillary Clinton campaign.
And a lot of these companies say,
we're afraid that if Hillary Clinton wins,
she'll take away our FCC license.
So it's, it's, it's this,
it's this economic issue that is inherent
in media and it requires independent
people to do something about it because
the networks are not going to do
something about it. They are, they're
in the business of generating a profit.
It's so fascinating to me because it's
like they're not even in the business.
Right. I get it. So they're in the
business making a profit and that's fine.
That is what businesses,
but they're not even in the business
of pretending anymore because it's like
during the whole Mueller investigation,
every week there was another leak to
the New York Times and it's always an
anonymous leak.
And then for the last two years they ran
anonymous leak stories and it's like,
shouldn't have, somebody had been
investigating why the Mueller, uh,
operation is leaking. That actually
would have been a story. Right.
Where was that story out
of the New York Times?
Well they had and James Clapper and
John Brennan and Munis or intelligence
clapper who lied under oath.
Is there intelligence agency people and
maybe not the most always ethical people
and they're just parroting what they're
told on on TV things or when things are,
and again, I go back to this whole
distinction and because when you,
when you report from a podium, when you
say something in a press conference, the,
the damage to society
done by broadcasting,
what you are told on the record is often
more pernicious than the damage that
say I do by deceiving some guy in a bar
so that I can get the truth out of them.
It is a, it is a huge difference. And,
and I think that journalists
tend to be that you,
you sort of have to play confidence games.
You know,
you have to seduce your source so
to speak. But there's, there is,
there's a two,
there's a relationship between sources
and the media that I think has become
corrupt.
I think that the,
the anonymous or the reliance upon
anonymous sources has become corrupted.
You look at Bob Woodward, legendary
reporter that gives a great journalist.
By the way, I don't think these
journalists are bad journalists.
I don't even think they're bad people.
I think they're part of an industrial
system of production that that
manufactures the public's consent.
But you look at Bob Woodward,
he writes a book called fear and he,
he uses quotes secondhand from
anonymous sources on background,
on deep background,
hearsay quotes and then he
recreates events and he puts that,
those events in quotation marks.
And I get attacked for selective editing.
I don't report anything unless you can
hear and see it come out of the person's
own mouth.
So I think that,
I think that journalism has become
corrupted due to this overreliance upon
sources,
anonymous sources especially.
And I think that that's
why we need videotapes.
I literally remember being in like junior
high school and watching CNN and they
would say a source on Capitol Hill.
And I would always think this is insane.
What sources I Capitola
anyone can be on Capitol Hill.
It could be the guy that's walking his
dog on Capitol Hill who is the janitor
for the, you know, fast
food joint. We don't,
we don't see or we don't
see that sources face.
We don't know what motivates that person.
We don't know what words were used.
You know that that person exists. We
don't know if that person exists. I mean,
can you imagine if I said
there are sources inside CNN,
he says that Jeff Zucker said they'd
call me a liar. Yeah. And, and, and I,
and there's an analogy here.
I heard someone say that when
you use an anonymous source,
it's like you're taking withdrawal
out of a bank account of credibility,
but you have to deposit into the bank
account, trust with the audience.
And nowadays we don't see these,
we don't see these anonymous sources
we see on an over reliance upon.
And every time you actually
opened the reporter's notebook,
every time you look at the transcript,
every time you see the raw data there,
there is a, there is a difference
between what you are told and,
and by the people that are
asking you to trust them.
But that's the bottom line. These, these,
these immediate companies don't
trust us with the raw information.
They don't want us to have the raw,
unfiltered truth.
They need to propagandize
us with their version of it.
It's crazy once you see it, right,
like once you really clearly see it.
Like I was actually in the green room
with Jordan Peterson while he was being
interviewed by Nellie Bowles who was the
author of the New York Times who made
that whole Brouhaha about
enforced monogamy and it's like,
that is not what this conversation
was about. Or I had a whole day here,
literally an entire day from 8:00 AM
to about APM with a journalist for a
journalist from a der Spiegal who then
wrote a piece about me and labeled me the
grand allusionist of the alt right.
Yeah. They leave their labels. They did.
There's a light and know this at the time,
but there's a law in Germany that
if you're going to print something,
a quote from somebody,
you have to get the quote cleared.
So he spends all day with me,
hours of hours and hours and hours.
He doesn't quote me once. Wow. I mean
that's the level that, what is that?
It's not selective editing.
Yeah.
They called me the master of
ceremonies instead of an anchor.
They used the master of ceremonies.
I mean just like what the Washington
Post Guy, there was nothing.
I was like grand man.
The Washington Post,
this printed like five attractions
just in reporting about me.
It's like these guys have the
audacity to claim that I'm a liar.
In one article they said what the latest
project Veritas video leaves out and
the actual fact that I allegedly left
out was that this CNN producer that we
recorded was based in Atlanta.
Supposedly this was a big fat,
but I didn't leave it out.
It was in the video.
The Washington Post had
to print a retraction that
that they didn't change the
headline. What the what the video left
out. They retracted the entire thing.
There's another thing in the Washington
Post about this book fear and there was
a quote that said,
there's no evidence that he did not
say the things attributed to him in
referencing. There's no evidence. He
did not sell that. This is, you know,
we live in this weird world and I think
that videotape cuts through all the
propaganda,
like a hot knife through butter.
If you catch these people on video tape,
they're forced to address it.
And I think that video is, is, that's
why we choose the medium of video,
because words, words do not
transfix in a way that video does.
And I think that words are the,
frankly,
the propagandists tool because they put
you in a box by calling you names like
that. My calling the masters of
ceremonies by calling you what you were,
you're not what that is. You are. You got,
I know we could trade these stories all
day long. I'll just give you a one more.
But that same reporter from
New York Times, Nellie Bowles,
she wrote the story when
Peterson and I left Patrion.
They actually did a story on it,
which was quite shocking.
It's a horrible story filled with
factual errors. But even there,
there's a quote from the head of trust
and safety, a patriot and where she says,
you know,
you're not allowed to say these words on
our platform except so as I'm sure you
know Carl Benjamin is are going to occur.
I've never said those
words on their platform.
I contacted the author and it's like she
just doesn't care and she knows she's
not going to get fired and why even
tell the truth. So it's like they,
they just don't,
one thing that people are doing and more
frequency is recording their interviews
with these people that we,
and that's something that I would
encourage as long as it's legal to do so.
But you're on the record. So it's, it's,
it's legal because they're consenting to
the conversation even in, in California.
And we had one individual inside
CNN record, Alison Camera,
she does a long panel discussion about
voter fraud that cut the tape right
before the guy actually
brought up instances.
So something that people are doing now,
is there audio recording these interviews
for that reason and releasing the full
interview on Youtube?
Right.
So we've seen a lot of that actually
Tommy Robinson has done that. Right?
This guy, Avi Yemeni has done that with
a yes, this Jim J. I would not. I would,
I would employ your audience,
never do an interview with the
press unless you audio tape it.
And that's for your own, um, for
your own protection for sure.
The other thing you can do,
at least in our situation,
I really only do these shows now.
If it's live right, if it's alive,
you can edit me.
You might be able to sandbag me and I
have to be smart enough to work with that,
but you at least can edit me.
So Andrew Breitbart was my,
one of my mentors and he would take
this very, we were different people,
but he would take this perspective of,
you know, just as much press as possible.
I'm proudly who I am. I guess it
was a different world 10 years ago,
but he would do, he would
just give them everything. Um,
I think that there's two different ways
to play it, but we certainly to record,
uh, the interviews is a good, a good path.
And some people are leaking us
these audio tapes and we put the,
we put the long version out on Twitter
and Alison Camerata at CNN was so
humiliated by this raw version of the
interview that she actually removed she,
she left Twitter because people were
tweeting at her while all this, uh,
all these angry tweets. So we talked
a little bit about anonymous sources.
What do you make of just
like the anonymous accounts
all over the platforms that
often are the drivers of a lot of
the bad behavior. So for example,
there are anonymous accounts that have 20,
30,
40,000 followers that I see all day long,
selectively editing video clips
of me or just any, you know,
any decent human being.
And it's like they can do it with complete
impunity because their names aren't
attached to any of this. And what,
what are you going to do? What,
what do we do in situations? I mean, I,
I've got people impersonating
me and I'm not verified.
I got 500,000 followers that this morning.
I don't know who else.
I guess there's Julian Assan.
She's also not verified. Um,
I don't know how to solve these problems.
I don't know what the public
policy solutions are. My,
my perspective. And I mean,
everyone asked me what do we do about it?
I say the solution is
to inform the people.
The solution is to show people
the rot, the corruption, to,
to rake the muck as it were, to be a
muckraker to illuminate all the problems.
Because I think the solutions become self
evident when people know that there's
a guy in a room in San Francisco
arbitrarily determined, oh,
we're going to take away and
take away the blue check mark.
We don't like that guy's politics film
that show people those conversations
behind closed doors because then they
can't get it. There's impunity. They,
they can't get away with it. And,
and that's the, that is the solution.
The solution is to expose it. Um,
what, I mean, I can't believe that I'm,
I mean, I, on one hand,
I don't want to complain about it because
it makes it me feel like I'm, you know,
ingratiating myself to Twitter.
I'm not,
I'm not a verified human being
or a platform. And I and, and,
and why not? What is the
definition of, of being verified.
But certainly when you are verified, it
does help your, your stories get out.
It does. It's people know
that it's actually you and
I'm sure you've had people,
many people impersonating me. I don't,
I don't know what the solution is,
but I know that to find the solution we
have to properly identify the problem
and educate the people
with what they're saying.
You need a mole in the verified
department who can just click that button.
Maybe we already have one. Ah, it's, they
always question is whether to cut bait.
If you will be,
if you will be verified with your blue
check by the time this video goes up,
I will be very impressed.
That would be amazing.
That'll be interesting somehow I think
you haven't been sitting on that one.
Now the question with undercover
work is when do you cut bait?
Because you have these people who are in
on the inside and then you have to make
an editorial decision on
when do we release the story?
Like we have people right now, right now
as I speak inside the big networks, um,
who work for them.
They come to me and they are so sick by
how these companies project themselves.
You know, all the news that's fit to
print, the most trusted name in news.
That is not what they hear in, in
the newsrooms. They here, they,
I mean we had one person
say that people were crying,
they were crying the night of the
election at the Washington Post.
Everyone was sobbing and the things that
were being said that night would shock
you.
So these people come to me,
we're calling it the be brave initiative
and we think that the heroes are,
these are these individuals
on the inside and,
and I think that they'll blow the
whistle, they'll tape them. That works.
And hopefully that that will change
people's perception of big media once and
for all. How do you think a
Trump somehow understood this?
How is it that this orange man with crazy
hair somehow understood that like this
wasn't like he was,
you know,
he was always sort of a Twitter
troll and doing this thing.
And he understood the celebrity and he
understood public relations in business
obviously. But this very specific thing
that we've been talking about for the,
for the last hour,
Trump really seems to understand this.
Do you have any sense of what that is?
My perspective is that it was about earned
media. They was about generating are.
I think that there was some something
written about this where he,
his advisor said, you can't run
this campaign on earned media alone.
You have to be more traditionally
said the hell I can't watch me.
And he got some, I don't know how much it
was, five, $10 billion in earned media.
It's this, it's this notion
of, I think a lot of people,
particularly on the conservative
side of the spectrum,
tend to complain about wine, about, you
know, the mainstream media. They, they,
they, I call it the conservative ghetto.
They stay talking to themselves. But,
but then there's this other vision where
you were, you, you, you hack the media,
you, you, you participate in
the media. It's again, going
back to Andrew Breitbart,
he would, he would, um, uh,
love to go on these shows
that the definition of success
is being covered by the
mainstream media in it's, it's, it's
a tough dance because they attack you,
they call you and Julie, you know,
Jordan names and those sorts of things.
But if you play it the right way
and he covered by the media, that's,
that's real power.
And Trump understood that he could
win the election with earned media.
It was absolutely brilliant. Nobody else
saw it. Everyone thought he was nuts.
But he won the election on earned
media on getting these big ABC, CBS,
NBC New York Times to, to cover him,
to talk about him. It was brilliant.
It was amazing. And everyone thought
he couldn't, it couldn't be done.
And he did it. And I, and by
the I have the same vision,
although on a lesser
degree I tell my team,
I tell my employees,
the definition of success is to get on
the front page of the New York Times.
Because in Manhattan,
what, what you, you know,
people have to realize is that if
it is not in the New York Times,
it does not exist.
They don't pay attention
to things on the outside.
I hate to give them that power, but
it's still true to a degree. So to,
to be successful is to be covered
by the people that we hate.
And also,
and also not to get stuck where we
want to be loved by those people. Yes.
But because that's the problem. That is,
that is the problem. We want to be loved.
And Rush Limbaugh says, you know, I,
I learned that to be hated
as a sign of success.
And that's where a lot of Republicans
go wrong. Trump did not go wrong.
A lot of Republicans want to be loved
by the New York Times, by politico.
Um, it's tempting. I want to be loved
you. Everyone wants to be loved,
but we're going to be hated for what
we say and do. So it's being co,
so Trump's getting covered by them, but
he also calls them fake news. Brilliant.
It's Andrew Breitbart 2.0 all right.
So in, in summation here, if you had to,
if you were in the predictions game,
where do you see the platforms do,
do you sense that the way we
communicate right now we're,
we're all on these things and we're all
subjected to these objective rules and
seemingly arbitrary decisions and all
of those things. Do you sense that five,
10 years from now it's going to still
be the same or do you think that things
are going to massively change?
They are only going to change
if independent citizens
have the courage and the
willpower to do something about it?
I don't trust the politicians.
I don't trust the people on television
to do anything about it because they're
stuck in the status quo
and they're fat and happy.
It's going to require citizens,
independent people. You know,
some of these insiders,
I know some of them and others,
they have to blow the whistle. They have
to summon the righteous indignation.
I think that journalism has the
power to change hearts and minds,
real investigative reporting,
uh, to, to be the, uh,
what has been called the
custodians of conscience.
And if we can shock that people,
show them what's going on
behind the closed doors, I
think it can change things.
If that does not happen,
I think we'll enter a brave new
world where that doesn't happen.
We're a long gun, right? Yeah, but,
but, but, but, but there are people,
I know these people,
they're going to blow the whistle.
But if that does not happen, then
we're going to enter a brave new world.
But where the story has to be so big,
here's the silver lining.
Even if we get banned,
even if you get banned and I get band,
everyone gets banned,
the stories will come out and other
people will share them proxies,
we'll share them and they'll
share the information that,
that people will have a right
to know that we'll want to see.
But I think it's going
to require an effort by,
by independent citizens and brave
patriots willing to blow the whistle.
That is the only saving grace I
can see for this country. Uh, the,
the heroes amongst us, they, they
can, uh, to pitch a little bit.
They can go to our website
and I will give them a camera.
I will pay their legal bills,
I will hire them if they
are fired by their employer.
Twitter and Facebook have not sued me.
I get sued a lot.
I have not been sued by those companies.
They do not want to give heft and weight
to the stories that we have unmasked.
They do not want to give us free
publicity. So there is a, uh,
a strategy here to,
to hold these people accountable.
I'm going to ask you one more actually,
which is,
I've asked this of a few of my guests
that I think are on the forefront of
saying on popular things are doing work
that is challenging and interesting way.
What is it about you? Why, why,
why do you James O'keefe
put your ass on the line
if I, if, if very tasks went away
tomorrow and I had no employees,
I'd be out hustling on the street
with a cam quarter and this is I,
this is what I was born to do.
Like I can't do anything else.
And it goes back to this whole
idea of a justice complex,
like the acorn investigation
that cost me $1,000 to do.
I borrowed my grandmother's Chinchilla
coat, a camcorder that a friend gave me,
an a borrowed copy of final
cut pro and acorn was defunded.
Both houses of Congress are
democratically controlled.
President Obama signed the bill.
It doesn't take money to do this.
It doesn't take power to do
this. It takes, it takes will.
It takes the design.
It takes a belief in justice.
It takes a desire to to expose something,
to inform your fellow citizens and
finding people who are likeminded.
If they were to take away my organization,
I'd be doing this the rest of my life.
I had nothing else I could
do because I believe in it.
I actually believe in what I'm doing
and the people that I find I have,
I have a profound responsibility
to serve the the people,
to tell the truth to the people and people
coming forward that want to blow the
whistle. This is, this is
why Veritas now exists,
is to equip those people
and to protect them.
I'd be willing to go to jail to
protect a source. I have been to jail.
I've been incarcerated. I've been
sued. I've been set up. It's not,
it's not the worst thing.
The worst thing is not to to serve the
people that come to me and want to tell a
story,
and that's why we exist and we're
going to keep doing it until people are
honest.
On that note,
you can follow James and Project Veritas
on Twitter for as long as they're still
on Twitter.
It's at project underscore very tough.